on va passer à l'actualité de la semaine
de la semaine des semaines qui ont
précédé de la semaine à venir enfin
c'est un feuilleton qui n'en finit plus
on va parler de la loi immigration
Quentin l'examen commence au Sénat lundi
c'est le Sénat qui s'enare du texte en
premier voilà roulement de tambourg
c'est effectivement ce lundi 6 novembre
que commence l'examen ici au Sénat du
projet de loi on peut dire aussi de tous
les dangers pour l'exécutif un texte
dont on parle depuis très longtemps
Orian puisqu'il a été évoqué dès l'été
2022 présenté à la presse en novembre
202 22 rappelez-vous à l'époque les
visages de deux ministres s'affichent
dans le journal Le Monde géralde daran
pour le volet efficacité de la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale et Olivier
dus sopte ministre du Travail ancien
socialiste pour le volet intégration par
le travail avec des titres de séjour
pour les travailleurs dans certains
secteurs en tension où l'on peine à
recruter car ce texte se voulait
initialement et se veut toujours
équilibré avec ses deux jambes ces deux
idées intégration par le travail mais
aussi lutte contre l'immigration
illégale et ça avait été résumé dès
novembre 2022 par cette formule dans la
presse régionale être gentil avec les
gentils méchants avec les méchants
c'était des termes qui avait utilisé
géralde Darman et alors très vite ça
c'est compliqué dès l'automne 2022 on
voit des lignes rouges apparaître voilà
des lignes rouges apparaissent dès
l'automne 2022 et on peut dire aussi que
la réforme des retraites a laissé des
traces car la majorité présidentielle
comprend qu'il faut négocier fautees de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
négocier notamment avec les LR or les LR
ne veulent pas de l'article 3 du texte
celui sur les fameux titres de séjour
dans les métiers en tension écoutez le
chef du parti Éric Coti c'était il y a
encore quelques jours sur France
interre
si il y a toujours cette mesure de
régularisation des clandestins nous
l'avons toujours dit nous ferons en
sorte que ce texte ne passe pas et s'il
y a l'arme de la motion de censure pour
faire en sorte qu'il ne passe pas qu'il
ne metent pas en mesure cette
disposition dangereuse nous la voterons
bien sûr et nous la déposerons même et
Quentin l'affaire se complique encore
pour le gouvernement car l'aile gauche
de la majorité présidentielle refuse de
voter C Tex il y a pas d'article 3 voilà
l'aile gauche de la macronie
effectivement alors c'est peut-être une
trentaine de députés ils mettent
également la pression il y a par exemple
le président de la commission des lois
de l'Assemblée nationale il s'appelle
Sacha Houlier et lui et bien il insiste
sur le fait qu'il faut que cet article 3
soit bien présent dans le projet de loi
pour qu'il puisse le voter et pendant un
temps les centristes ont semblé avoir
trouvé un compr pris qui satisfaisait
tout le monde au lieu de passer par la
loi passer par le règlementaire pour cet
article 3 écoutez le chef de fil des
centristes au Cénat RV
Marseille les républicains sont d'accord
avec nous pour dire on peut rectifier
tout ça par voie circulaire c'est la
circulaire B on la rectifie bon très
bien le seul point le seul point c'est
que dans l'article dans un article de la
loi l'article 3 ou un autre on puisse
dire qu'on va changer la circulaire
parce que à l'assemblée il y a des gens
qui vous disent s'il y a pas ça on vote
pas et eux ils disent si on le met on
vote pas problème c'est de savoir si on
veut ou si on veut pas que ce texte soit
voté ça c'est un autre sujet mais il
faut assumer à ce moment-là qu'on arrête
toutes ces palidonies sur un malheureux
article qui mérite pas tout ça voà en
tout cas ouis ben l'idée elle a été
balayé voilà l' l'idée a été balayée par
par les àer qu'ils ne veulent tout
simplement pas du tout de cet article 3
et qui font même d'autres propositions
les LR pour aller encore plus loin dans
ce projet de loi immigration ce qui rend
donc encore plus compliqué l'idée d'un
accord autour de ce texte entre le
gouvernement et la droite regardez
certaines de leurs propositions la
transformation de l'aide médicale d'État
en aide médicale d'urgence avec donc que
certains soins uniquement concernés le
durcissement des conditions du
regroupement familial ou encore la
réforme de la procédure d'octroit de la
nationalité l'équation est donc très
compliquée pour géralde Darmanin et le
gouvernement l'accord avec lesalr semble
très difficile à trouver c'est à suivre
à partir de lundi d'ailleurs nous serons
en édition spéciale sur l'antenne de
public sat pour tout suivre et on suivra
tout ça est-ce que ce projet de loi
immigration c'est chronique d'un
compromis impossible bah c'est
évidemment chronique d'un compromis qui
est compliqué en tout cas tout bêtement
parce que au-delà même du contenu du
texte dont on peut discuter parce que le
fait qu'on veille passer par voie
législative sur une disposition
réglementaire je dirais que pour le
juriste ça montre que en fait
fondamentalement ce projet n'était
peut-être pas utile en tout cas sur
beaucoup d'aspects on est sur quelque
chose qui relève beaucoup plus du
règlement ou qui interroge ensuite le
rapport à la hiérarchie des normes
fondamentalement on change 3 virgul donc
c'est un projet très politique et ce
projet très politique qui permet au
gouvernement de dire et bien et
notamment à géralde har Manin sur
l'immigration nous faisons quelque chose
sur l'immigration nous reprenons le
contrôle sur l'immigration nous existons
ça évidemment pour LR qui aujourd'hui
est pris en tenaille entre le
rassemblement national et la majorité
c'est quelque chose de difficile à
acceptter parce que si vous faites ce
cadeau à la majorité ben quel est
l'intérêt de LR quelle est la
spécificité de LR et ça évidemment et
ben ça implique d'avoir une position de
durcissement et infé une adoption plus
compliquée ouis oui je suis
personnellement la FA d'accord dans
cette guerre des trois blocs que l'on
connaît jusqu'à 2027 un bloc de gauche
nupes plus ou moins malade le bloc RN
solide et le bloc central où est où se
trouvait l'air et c'est vrai que sur la
question de l'immigration les
sympathisants et l'air penchent plutôt
du côté du rassemblement national même
si globalement il y a un durcissement du
pays sur la question fa migratoire on
parlera de l'actualité international du
terrorisme les Français de plus en plus
font le lien et c'était avant je te
dirais contenit seulement au marge de la
droite extrême entre insécurité et
immigration les arguments sur le lien
terrorisme immigration sont aussi
retenus par une part désormais
majoritaire de l'opinion donc c'est vrai
que c ce projet de loi qui a été comme
vous l'avez dit Quentin une véritable
harlaisienne ça fait plus d'un an qu'on
en parle est attendu de ce point de
vue-là les Français attendent ind
durcissement mais sur l'article 3 quand
on teste la possibilité de régulariser
des sans papiers dans les métiers en
tension on trouve une majorité de
mémoire 69 % dans dans une enqutifope au
mois de septembre y compris chez les
sympathis mais c'est vrai que LR doit
une fois de plus trouver un espace
vendre chz monimpô et c'est vrai que
suivre voter la loi quel bénéfice à
court terme dans l'opinion dans un
contexte il faut le dire maintenant
pré-électoral les européenes on lieu le
9 juin prochain on ne voit pas le
bénéfice à court terme il y a peut-être
aussi la question d'intérêt général qui
va pousser c'est vrai qu'il y a des
pression y compris du peuple de droite
sur l'idée que il faut avancer sur cette
question même si je le répète elle n'est
pas centrale dans les préoccupations des
frç estce est-ce qu'à contrario Frédéric
CLR bloque l'adoption de cette loi alors
qu'on voit dans les enquêtes d'opinion
que les Français la soutiennent et
demandent plus de fermeté ça va pas leur
revenir en boomerang oui d'autant plus
que les sympathisants on sont sur cette
logique de fermeté et sur les métiers la
régularisation des sans-papiers pour les
métiers en tension on trouve une petite
majorité de sympathisants LR le
durcissement est réel mais surtout et je
reprends le terme de Benjamin c'est une
question de reprise de contrôle les
Français ont le sentiment sur des
questions d'insécurité sur les questions
d'immigration que l'État ne contrôle
plus les choses donc c'est cette attente
là qui est absolument euh prégnante ce
qui n'empêche pas que le durcissement
peut s'arrêter sur l'accueil de réfugiés
c'est une question que l'on pose depuis
une vingtaine d'années notamment avec la
Fondation jeanores c'est le devoir de la
France d'accueillir des Français fillant
des réfugiés pardon fillant la guerre ou
la misère on retrouve systématiquement
une petite majorité de Français qui
répondent oui à cette affirmation donc
dur 6 oui mais c'est plus dans une
logique de reprise de contrôle et que
l'État soit maître chez lui sur cet
article 3 il y a un bras de fer entre
leslr et le gouvernement mais Quentin
l'a redit entre l'lr et les centristes
au sein de la majorité sénatoriale qui
est divisé sur cet article 3 est-ce que
l'lr risque de se retrouver en minorité
ici au Sénat alors en minorité c'est
possible mais il n'est pas certain qu'au
bout du compte ça fasse forcément non
plus les affaires du gouvernement parce
qu'un fini il faut qu'il soit voté votre
projet or S n'est pas voté par les LR
d'un côté et par la gauche de l'autre
pour d'autres raisons parce que sera pas
l'article 3 qui posera problème mais
l'ensemble des autres articles bah vous
n'allez pas faire une majorité
uniquement avec l'Union centriste vous
voyez donc ce faisant et bien vous
retrouver dans une situation qui est une
situation où le texte nétant pas adopté
au Sénat et bien ça devient compliqué à
l'Assemblée parce que quel est l'intérêt
du gouvernement de le faire adopter au
Sénat bah c'est d'avoir une commission
mixte paritaire qui Infiné soit plutôt
favorable au texte et puis d'engager
d'une façon plus ou moins grande le
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale sur un
texte qui sortirait du Sénat donc si
jamais le groupe LR au Sénat n'est pas
d'accord en soi c'est un problème après
ce qui est très très preignant dans ce
texte c'est qu'il est en train de
diviser les deux majorités si jamais il
divise la majorité sénatoriale c'est un
problème ici au Sénat mais derrière si
jamais il divise également la majorité
relative à l'Assemblée nationale avec
une lutte entre d'un côté la droite de
la majorité et
air potentiellement à aller chercher et
de l'autre la gauche avec sa chaouillet
et bien vous vous retrouvez avec deux
majorités en tension et ça évidemment ça
rend le quinena encore plus difficile
encore plus imprévisible parce que quand
vous avez une majorité é au Sénat avec
laquelle vous pouvez négocier bah c'est
un partenaire qui est un partenaire
compliqué mais au moins c'est un
partenaire oui et Benjamin vous vous
parliez de trouver une majorité d'abord
avec les LR du Sénat pour ensuite avoir
comme ça des garanties un peu plus
fortes auprès des LR de l'Assemblée
nationale sauf que c'est l'équation
qu'on avait vu pendant la réforme des
retraites et ça n'a pas du tout
fonctionné puisque c'est le texte voté
par la droite sénatorielle qui est
arrivé à l'Assemblée nationale et où il
a manqué 19 députés de mémoire LR pour
pour voter le texte il a fallu avoir
recours au 493 donc on se dit que céit
la différence quand même c'est que les
sur la question je trouve votre
comparaison très pertinente sur la
question des de la réforme des retraites
il y avait des LR de l'assemblée qui
étaient différents des LR du Sénat je
pense que sur la question en fait
migratoire il y aura beaucoup moins de
différences de points de vue de
différence idéologique LR est quand même
on voit dans les enquêtes d'opinion sur
leur représenté sur les sympathisants LR
sur ces questions je dirais en fusion
avec les sympathisants eren et les
sympathisants de reconquête et c'est
vrai que ça a pas marché sur le sur la
loi retraite en revanche si vous prenez
l'ensemble des textes depuis le début de
la législature c'est une technique
qu'utilise de manière assez majeure le
gouvernement et qui pour l'instant
fonctionne pas si mal en réalité donc ce
faisant on peut comprendre également que
pour le gouvernement bah c'est quand
même un engagement après quand vous
prenez les statistiques sur le groupe LR
à l'Assemblée c'est à part les groupes
typot le groupe qui vote le plus en
ordre dispersé donc aujourd'hui le
problème n'est pas tant d'engager une
chambre sur l'autre mais c'est en fait
une question de cohérence du groupe LR
le groupe LR à l'Assemblée c'est un
groupe de survivants après les dernières
législatives arrive à tenir ce groupe et
à le faire voter dans dans un seul sens
c'est vraiment une gageur vous parlez de
la cohérence du groupe l est-ce qu'il y
a une cohérence totale du côté du
gouvernement parce qu'on a entendu
Gérald armanin sur cette article 3 il y
a quelques jours dans le Journal du
Dimanche dire que finalement c'était pas
central et que il fallait pas passer du
temps sur des choses qui sont pas
centrales cette semaine il a dit que
finalement il y tenait mais d'un côté il
est prê un compromis avec leslr
c'est-à-dire évidemment qui se fera sur
cet article 3 est-ce que c'est vraiment
très clair du côté du gouvernement c'est
vrai que ce que vous rappelez montre une
certaine une certaine Godi maintenant je
pense que
les la majorité a une base et les
électeurs du bloc central les des
sympathisants Renaissance modem horizon
sans être aussi chauffé à blanc sur ces
questions veulent que ça bouge veulent
ce projet de loi alors c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas dans le contexte de du
précédent projet de loi immigration sous
Gérard colon justement ce qui avait été
très intéressant et
très en fait pertinent pour la majorité
LRM de l'époque c'est que elle
apparaissait comme un point d'équilibre
avec ce projet de loi entre une gauche
qu'il trouvait trop dure et une droite
trop laxist là cette grriille de lecture
sans doute marchera moins parce que
aussi il y a un contexte de durcissement
de l'opinion publique parce qu'il y a ce
lien qui d'ailleurs fait le premier
officiellement Gérald d'Anin entre
insécurité et immigr igration et on va
sans doute on va en parler l'actualité
met ces sujets au cœur de l'agenda des
Français oui alors le vrai danger entre
guillemets c'est pourquoi on a une forme
de je dirais de palinodi comme dirait
Hervé Marseille du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet c'est tout mement pour des raisons
politiques encore une fois cet article 3
on pourrait le faire passer par voie
règlementaire donc il est
essentiellement politique mais derrière
si vous ne l'avez pas vous n'avez pas la
gauche de votre majorité vous êtes
obligé du CIN 49 alignéat 3 or il faut
bien comprendre ce que ça signifie
utiliser un 49 alignéat 3 contre le
président de votre commission des Lois
ça s'est jamais vu utiliser le 49 aligné
3 contre une partie substantielle de
votre majorité quand en plus elle est
relative ça vous rappelle rien c'est les
lois Macron et l comerie vous avez vu
comment ensuite a tourné la majorité qui
pourtant était absolue et beaucoup plus
discipliné a priori que celle-ci à
l'époque de François Hollande donc c'est
extrêmement dangereux exactement ça veut
dire que vous rompez votre majorité vous
frustrez votre majorité et vous lui
dites on en a rien à faire de ce que tu
es en train de dire en réalité on fera
passer le texte quoi qu'il arrive pour
faire plaisir au qu'and en facee
c'est-à-dire à l'opposition LR ça ça
rque de laisser des traces or
aujourd'hui le gouvernement de créer des
frondeurs exactement n'a pas la capacité
de gérer ça oui un mot aussi sur le fait
qu'on avait entendu une rumeur aussi la
semaine dernière entre des négociations
directement à matigon entre ellisabeth
borne et le chef de fil deslr Bruno
retaillot et on avait cru comprendre
après leurs échanges que ellisabeth
borne avait fait savoir au LR du Sénat
qu'elle était même prête à abandonner
l'article 3 il avait fallu ensuite et
bien que le gouvernement revienne sur
ces déclarations qui étaient un peu
faites en off avec
avec et et donc on voit qu'effectivement
dans les négociations avec les les LR du
Sénat on se perd un peu sur jusqu'où est
prêt à aller le gouvernement dans les
dans les dans le compromis qu'il veut
trouver avec la Dre je pense que c'est
en rupture avec ce qu'attendent les
Français ils sont pas sur une logique de
jeu en chambre de petites négociations
de petites manœuv sur une logique
d'efficacité et maintenant tout ce que
vous racontez je pense que les Français
ne le voient pas ne s ne s'y intéresse
absolument pas donc c'est les Français
ils attendent une loi Fréd je pense que
oui je pense que oui et je pense parce
que maintenant l'immigration n'est plus
un enjeu je
dirais isolé mais les Français a tort ou
a raison mais c'est comme ça l'insrivve
dans toute une série d'enjeux qui
remettent en cause l'autorité de l'État
la maîtrise des frontières la sécurité
la délincance l'identité et on est dans
ce contexte très particulier l'Ifop a
publié avec Fiducial le figuero et SUD
RADIO cette semaine une enquête
d'attention de pour l'élection
présidentielle Gérald Danin qui est au
cœur de ces sujets gagne 5 points de
potentiel électoral par rapport à une
enquête faite fin avril d'une part et
quand on fait l'addition des intentions
de vote une addission un peu hardie
Laurent voquier dupontignan Marine Le
Pen Éric zébour on est presque à 47 48 %
d'attention de vote qui a le plus à
perdre Benjamin si politiquement si la
loi n'aboutit pas bah je dirais que
c'est probablement la majorité Elisabeth
bande serait évidemment déstabilisée
mais Gérald harmanin serait également
dans une situation qui risque d'être
compliquée je voulais revenir rapidement
sur sur ce que disait Frédéric sur la
reprise de contrôle je crois que c'est
essentiel parce qu'en réalité les
Français attendent une loi sur la
reprise de contrôle mais la frustration
risque d'être grande je rappelle souvent
ces chiffres on a une loi sur
l'immigration toutes les 3 ans on en a
eu 29 depuis 1980 le problème
aujourd'hui il est pas législatif une
loi ça rend pas plus exécutoire les TF
ull noise ça ne remet pas en cause la
hiérarchie des normes avec le droit
européen et donc c'est vrai que là il y
a une attente une attente qui est créée
parce qu'elle est tisée une attente qui
est créée parce que politiquement elle
est mise en scène derrière il avoir
beaucoup de frustration et ça ben au
bout du compte ça rejoint un phénomène
qui est un phénomène électoral où ce
sujet devient un sujet de mobilisation
électorale pour une partie de la droite
et si la loi n'aboutit pas la grille de
lecture qui s'installe de plus en plus
et c'est une surprise comparé au quinena
précédent de l'inaction un gouvernement
un président qui ne transforme plus qui
ne réforme plus exceptter cette réforme
des retraites ça peut être assez
dévastateur parce que cette grille de
lecture qui avait été par exemple très
fortement associé au quinquena de
François Hollande et toujours vastatrice
parce que ça crée l'envie d'une rupture
et de voir en 2027 un candidat une
candidate émerger en dehors de ce bloc
majoritaire et on suivra bien évidemment
Quentin vous l'avez dit un lundi à
partir de 16h l'examen de ce projet de
loi immigration avec vous ce sera à
suivre sur notre antenne on va passer à
l'autre thème de ce club et et
l'actualité de cette semaine qui a été
marqué par la montée de ces actes
antisémites Frédérique vous avez réalisé
un sondage sur le sentiments des
Français visà de ce conflit
israëlo-palestinien vous avez posé la
question craignez-vous que le conflit
israélo-palestinien a des répercussions
en France 82 % des Français ont dit oui
oui ce chiffre est extrêmement fort il
s'inscrit dans un contexte général qui
est que l'époque où l'international
était un horizon lointain n'intéressait
personne sauf des segments de
population un petit peu spécifiqu les
personnes âgées les personnes diplômés
des CADES c'est absolument fini on l'a
vu sur toute une série de sujets des
sujets climatiques des sujets en
environnementaux au moment du covid et
cetera maintenant et sur ce sujet
inflammable qui est celui du
ProcheOrient et du conflit
israélopestinien le chiffre est
extrêmement fort c'est l'idée que ce
conflit lointain dans une petite zone
géographique s'invite chez nous et les
Français le voient avec la la résurgence
des actes antisémites et c'est partagé
dans toutes les familles politiques et
je pense que il y a ce contexte général
de l'international qui peut nous
concerner directement et puis aussi ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre et
l'émotion qu'il y a eu dans le pays sur
les crimes du Hamas c'est aussi l'idée
ça réactivé un traumatisme en France
celui du 13 novembre celui des attentats
de 2015 de 2016 puisque par exemple les
meurtres les assassinats lors de la r
parti dans le désert bah c'est une sorte
de Bataclan à ciel ouvert dans nos
enquêtes ça a très fortement je dirais
réactivé cette crainte et le chiffre est
fort he 72 % des Français dans cette
enquête il FOP pour le CRIF que le figer
avait publié la semaine dernière
considérer que un des attentats ou des
crimes terroristes comme ceux du Hamas
pourrait se reproduire en France c'est
quand même très fort et c'est partagé là
dans toutes les familles politiques le
clivage LFI versus les autres familles
politiques là n'existe pas ouais
Benjamin ce sont effectivement deux
chiffres qui sont très élevés hein sont
deux chiffres qui sont très élevés et
qui rappellent que quand même même si ce
conflit en effet est une affaire
étrangère elle est toujours été
considéré également un peu comme une
affaire interne c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
toujours une identification de la
population à ce conflit depuis en
réalité des décennies sauf peut-être
depuis 10 ou 15 ans où on a un conflit
qui é en bloqué du point de vue du
processus de paix et quelque peu passer
sous les radars et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que la politisation
ces dernières années et bien aujourd'hui
est une est une politisation peut-être
beaucoup plus beaucoup moins informé et
donc ce faisant on a des clivages qui
sont des clivages beaucoup plus
exacerbés vous savez la fois où Michel
Rocard beré goovvois et où cresson
utilise la responsabilité du
Gouvernement devant au Parlement lors du
gouvernement minoritaire de 88 à 93
c'est sur des sujets de politique
internationales en revanche on a vu ici
lors de enfin à l'Assemblée nationale
lorsque le gouvernement a fait une
déclaration que aujourd'hui les sujets
de politique international ne sont plus
des sujets de consensus et ça ça marque
réellement une époque et cette époque-là
bien évidemment elle devient extrêmement
inflammable et et Frédéric dans dans ce
sondage vous avez posé également la
question au français pour savoir s'ils
étaient satisfaits ou mécontents de
l'attitude de nos leaders po
on va peut-être commencer par Emmanuel
Macron c'est très partagé oui mais il y
a quand même un
effet drapeau petit puisque quand on
avait on avait été marqué au mois
d'octobre par une chute de la confiance
sur l'action d'Emmanuel Macron sur les
questions internationales qu'on avait
jamais eu alors que traditionnellement
les Français sont très bienveillants et
très plutôt positifs sur l'action
internationale des chefs de l'État là on
a plutôt un score particulièrement élevé
il arrive en tête de la hiérarchie voilà
tout à fait suivi je crois cro de
desborn de
géraldmanin on a les parce que Gérald
d'manin on lui fait confiance pour
lutter contre l'antisémitisme non ce qui
est très ce qui est très nottable
au-delà d'Emmanuel Macron c'est la
hiérarchie entre Marine Le Pen et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen qui a
part un niveau particulièrement élevé
bienel là de son audience électorale et
très clairement le perdant sur cette
séquence c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon 82 %
des Français sont mécontents de son
attitude et ses prises de position mais
ce qu' frappe c'est qu'on en retrouve
une petite majorité de mémoire 54 %
d'électeurs du 10 avril 2022 du premier
tour de jour mon à se montrer mécontent
là aussi comme sur d'autres sujets comme
sur en fait la BAA comme sur son refus
de condamner les émeute urbaine de la
fin juin il est en décalage avec une
partie importante de son électorat il
est le grand perdant de cette séquence
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a une stratégie
de mobilisation électorale de sa part
alors est-ce que cette stratégie peut
être payante est-ce qu'il peut
solidifier un électorat en pensant que
inchin Ben le reste de l'électorat qui
pourrait voter pour lui de toute façon
reviendra au berkaaille c'est une
stratégie qui est risquée après Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pensant sur le temps long à
chaque fois on le donne entre guillemets
perdant il parvient malgré tout à
remobiliser ça est-ce que là c'est
quelque chose c'est le coup de trop
entre guillemets ou est-ce que c'est une
stratégie qui à court terme à moyen
terme et plus ou moins bien pensée en
tout cas dans une perspective de second
tour si on en est là évidemment c'est un
boulet au pied parce que ça crée un
clivage très très profond alors que la
stratégie de Marine Le Pen qui est une
stratégie de N noralisation qui est une
stratégie de banalisation et de
présidentialisation bien est plutôt la
grande gagnante en la matière de la
séquence donc on voit que les stratégies
sont différentes à long terme en effet
je crois que celle de Marine Le Pen
apparaît aujourd'hui plus pertinente
pour elle un dernier mot oui et elle est
en rupture totale une fois de plus et en
distinction avec son père qui avait été
soupçonné d'antisémitisme après le
détail après du Rafour crématoire après
avoir parlé je crois d'international
juive là c'est le signe ultime de cette
banalisation de cette cette
normalisation lorsqu'elle dit que le
rassemblement national est le parti le
plus amême de défendre les Français de
confessions ou de culture juive et une
partie importante des Français le croi
quand on voit ce sondage quand on voit
un autre sondage pour SUD RADIO où
c'était le rassemblement national qui
avait été perçu comme le plus juste sur
la question des crimes du Hamas et de ce
conflit au ProcheOrient merci Benjamin
merci vous restez avec nous c'est
vendredi on découvre notre patrimoine
comme tous les vendredis et Flora
sauvage nous emmène à la découverte du
Château de Sedan il citadelle qui a été
élu monument préféré des Français on
regarde on le surnomme le géant des
ardenes avec ses 35000 m Carr répartis
sur se étages et ses murs de 7 m
d'épaisseur le Château de Sedan surprend
de prime àord par sa taille il y a 1000
an Sedan n'existe pas ou en tout cas
c'est un simple village et sous nos
pieds il n'y a qu'un Épron rocheux sur
cet Épron rocheux viennent s'installer
des moines bénédictin qui dépend de
laabaye de Mouson mais au début du 15e
siècle Érard i de la marque va s'emparer
du prieuré pour entreprendre la
construction du château en 1424 un
seigneur allemand voit le potentiel
stratégique et économique de ce de ce
site et donc il décide tout de suite de
fortifier ce prioré en réutilisant
certaines parties de l'ancien bâtiment
monastique et ces enfants ces petits
enfants vont n'avoir de cess que
d'agrandir cette cette propriété et ce
qui est un peu particulier ici c'est que
au lieu de détruire au fur et à mesure
que la technologie faisait que les murs
n'étaient plus assez épais ou que les
meurtrières n'étaient plus des bonnes
dimensions et bien ils les ont construit
par-dessus et donc c'est ce qui va
permettre d'étendre le château d' au
début d'un château assez rustique assez
banal de de 1000 m² à aujourd'hui 35000
m² et donc c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
c'est le plus grand château fort
d'Europe le château est un château fort
il a servi pour la guerre il a accueilli
des Princes à un moment donné donc des
parties ont été aménagé de manière très
confortable d'où la présence de fenêtes
mais initialement rappelez-vous c'est un
château fort une forte forteresse
militaire pas besoin de jolies fenêtres
ce sont des points faibles allons-y
arrive la fin du 16e siècle et il y a un
changement de dynastie avec la famille
des la Tour d'Auvergne donc c'est la la
deuxième famille prinère de San le
rejeton le plus connu de cette famille
c'est bien sûr turen le grand turen
maréchal de France qui est né au Château
de Sedan et qui est mort en bataille un
peu plus tard mais c'est vraiment ça
fait partie de la grande histoire de de
France à travers la visite les
passionnés d'histoire vont à la
rencontre des illustres princes et
princesses de ce château classer
monument
historique gagner son indépendance et
construire sa gloire pour toujours
stratégiquement situé entre le royaume
de France et le Saint-Empire romain
germanique la ville demeura une
principauté pendant un
siècle animation démonstration de tir au
triébucher le château fort de San
multiplie les événements il a atteint
son record de fréquentation avec plus de
100000 visiteurs en
2022 vous avez le choix entre dégommer
le dragon qui est à droite mais
attention car à gauche il y a la
princesse dans le donjon donc si vous
visez mal vous pouvez attaquer la
princesse alors moi j'ai quand même
tendance à dire des princesses on en a
plein les dragons on en voit pas souvent
hop j'ai juste éviter de coincer la
fronde sera comme ça allez-y
[Applaudissements]
oh
oh trop loin malheureusement les gens se
rendent compte que il y a pas que les
grands châteaux de la Loire justement
qui sont à visiter mais qu' y a d'autres
monuments un peu moins connus qui
méritent d'être visiter à l'issue de
leur visite les touristes semblent
conquis ce château est gigantesque c'est
un magnifique château et je pense qu'il
faut le visiter accompagné d'un guide
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'explications
indispensables qu'on ne découvrirait pas
par nous-même même pour les enfants et
tout ça pour leur dire que oui il a eu
quand même cette existence cette époque
de guerre et tout ça c'est vrai que moi
je pense que dès que mes petits enfants
vont venir dans le secteur je pense que
je vais les faire venir le château de
sedans célébrera ces 600 ans en 2024 une
occasion supplémentaire pour venir
découvrir cette forteresse injustement
méconnue voilà et ça donne envie d'y
aller on a fait un bon quelques siècles
en arrière très beau reportage sauage on
regarde ce qu' a la une de nos
quotidiens
[Musique]
régionx et Quentin évidemment on
commence avec la tempête carane à la Une
de beaucoup de nos journaux régionaux ce
matin voilà on voit de nombreux titres
partout en France comme si cette tempête
avait touché les quatre coins de la
France le Berry Républicain raconte
ainsi que 2000 foyers ont été touchés
dans le Cher mais c'est bien surûr le
nord-ouest de la France qui a été le
plus touché Paris Normandie raconte les
chutes d'arbres et autres frayeurs qui
ont touché ran prese océan àant raconte
qu'une dig du port du lerra à Piriac
surmer à cédé Oriane et une édition
spéciale du télégram le journal breton
voilà la Bretagne paralysée en lettre
capitale peut-on lire effectivement dans
le journal de Bresque qui raconte cette
cette nuit dentesque et la mobilisation
exceptionnelle pour faire face à cette
bombe météorologique je cite avec des
rafales impressionnantes jusqu'à 207 kmh
à la pointe du rat récit à lire dans les
pages intérieures cela restera un
événement gravé dans nos mémoires
raconte la commandant Virginie Jouan du
10 29 enfin dans le journal on lit le
sens du prénom Kirian orien le petit nom
de cette tempête Kirian c'est un nom
d'origine gaéique qui renvoie à l'idée
d'obscurité voire même d'enfer bien
choisi visiblement quand on lit le récit
de la nuit dernière autre récit c'est di
ce matin celui de la communauté juive de
la Côte d'Azur sur le qui VI voilà il y
a bien une recrudesens aussi dans cette
région des actes antisémites avec 34
plaintes qui ont été déposées depuis le
7 octobre dans les pages intérieures la
communauté juive oscile entre inquiétude
et incompréhension et ce père qui
conseille à son fils de 11 ans dans la
rue enlève taakipa c'est vendredi on
termine avec un sujet plus léger Quentin
voilà on termine toujours avec un petit
sourire mais effectivement on va parler
un peu de gastronomie de cuisine pour
terminer avec ce fait maison qui est
plébiscité par les cuisiniers notamment
dans l'Est de la France voyez l'Est
Républicain il était grand temps
explique le chef étoilé Frédéric
sendrini d'ici 2025 tous les
restaurateurs devront signaler sur leur
carte les plats qui ne sont pas faits
maison alors c'est peut-être aussi
l'occasion pour nous he de se remettre à
cuisiner pourquoi pas ce weekend ben
exactement surtout qu'il va pas faire
beau voilà et ben on va aller faire y a
d'autes dépression qui arrivve merci
beaucoup merci Quentin pour cette revue
de presse merci beaucoup Frédéric
d'avoir été avec nous merci Benjamin et
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi matin et puis lundi on le
rappelle Quentin vous pourrez suivre à
partir de 16h en direct sur notre
antenne édition spéciale début du projet
lo immigration ce sera sûr avec vous
Quentin merci beaucoup merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi on vous souhaite un
excellent weekend en cuisinant peut-être
pour suivre les conseils de Quentin bon
weekend